So how would scripts help inform the design of an agent to solve Raven's
progressive matrices? Remember,
scripts are ways of making sense of complex events in the world and
we can certainly consider individual Raven's matrices to be complex situations.
You thus might have a script for different broad categories of Raven's problems.
If this was your approach, what would your entry conditions be for each script?
What would the tracks be? What would the scenes be? Where are these scripts
going to come from? Are you going to tell the agent what script it should use or
will it learn a script from prior problems? If the agent succeeds using
the script that you give it, who is intelligent? You or your agent?